Most of the humor written with children in
mind is pretty on the nose.
And while a lot of it is definitely funny,
sometimes the adults in the room get a little
bored.
Parents almost never get the luxury of watching
a movie once, especially if it’s their kid’s
favorite.
So, working with their audience in mind, writers
and animators will occasionally embed tiny
pieces of mature content into their work.
When done correctly the jokes catch the attention
of the right people, but fly under the radar
of any youngsters who might be watching too.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Dirty Adult Jokes
Hidden In Popular Kids Movies.
The Emperor’s New Groove
Wordplay is a great way to launch a joke right
over a kid’s head.
And combining that with an innocent-looking
scene can take it to another level.
In The Emperor’s New Groove, the lovable
Kronk spends a night in the great outdoors.
And while kids may be laughing at the size
of his accommodations, everyone else is giggling
about what it really means to “pitch a tent.”
Sometimes the best place for a joke to hide
is in plain sight.
Toy Story 3
There are certain situations where, if they’re
not careful, even adults are likely to miss
a dirty quip here and there.
The Toy Story franchise is full of funny characters,
and some of them are fast-talkers.
So there’s actually an abundance of sly
nods to the parents in the crowd, but some
of them are disguised as throwaway lines.
For example, one scene in Toy Story 3 shows
the evil bear Lotso remove Mrs. Potato Head’s
mouth from her face.
And in his protest, her husband shouts some
choice words at the burly villain.
It happens so quickly that even some grown-ups
might miss it.
But is very obvious in retrospect.
Shrek
A few years ago, you’d be hard pressed to
find a parent who hadn't seen all the Shrek
movies at least a dozen times over.
The big green ogre muscled his way into living
rooms across the globe.
Multiple sequels followed which led to a holiday
special, and even a spinoff film for the character
of Puss in Boots.
Mercifully, the team behind the scenes included
a few doses of adult humor in the kid-friendly
franchise.
And parents were thankful.
First, the bad guy’s name is clearly an
allusion to the word “fuckwad.”
Plus, when Shrek and Donkey arrive at Farquaad’s
castle, they joke that maybe the royal uses
his home to distract from his small… family
jewels.
Aladdin 3: Aladdin and the King of Thieves
Aladdin scored huge points for Disney when
it was released in 1992.
And even though they were released straight
to video, the two sequels Return of Jafar
and King of Thieves were also well-received.
Spoiler alert: it takes Aladdin and Jasmine
almost three whole movies before they get
married.
And when they finally get the chance in the
third installment, the castle comes under
attack.
Thankfully for the characters, Genie is on
hand to help.
And thankfully for the parents, that means
the quick-witted genius Robin Williams.
Amidst all the chaos, the comedian spits out
a lightning-fast sex joke that maintains its
innocence so flawlessly, a lot of the parents
missed it too.
Madagascar
Things change when you become a parent.
Sleepless nights, hunger, and the sudden responsibility
of watching your mouth in front of an impressionable,
young brain.
But at the end of the day, we’re all subject
to our instincts, and sometimes we just have
to swear.
Thankfully, there’s a way to be sneaky about
it.
And in the 2005 movie Madagascar, Marty the
zebra shows us how.
After he and a few buddies escape from the
zoo, they find themselves on the island of
Madagascar.
After too long without a meal, his friend
Alex the lion gets so crazed with hunger that
he can’t control the instinct to hunt his
striped friend.
When Marty realizes what’s about to happen,
he yells “sugar honey iced tea”.
And you don’t need a degree in cryptology
to solve that anagram.
(S.H.I.T.)
Hercules
Greek mythology is full of characters.
And much like Game of Thrones, it can be hard
to keep all of them, and their storylines,
straight.
Even then, there’s a lot of variation when
it comes to the stories themselves.
So its just expected that everyone who takes
on the subject matter will put their own spin
on it.
In 1997, Disney released their take on a story
of Hercules.
And it has something for everyone, including
people who like their comedy low-brow.
Dirty minds should watch for a fight with
the centaur.
After the beast gets walloped by Hercules,
his head swells into the shape of a.. well,
you know.
Like we said: something for everyone.
Inside Out
Inside Out follows the story of a young girl
named Riley, who’s family moves across country
and leaves everything she knows behind.
Told through the lens of psychology, the storytellers
turn emotions into characters.
And use the girl’s mind as a landscape to
show how the change is affecting her personality.
Led by Joy, other emotions Sadness, Fear,
Anger, and Disgust also play a big part in
the film.
Shortly after Riley sees their new house in
San Francisco, Fear wonders aloud about the
city’s bear situation.
And Anger’s response made more than a few
people chuckle.
Bear is a slang word used in the LGBT community
that describes a particular body type.
Big and hairy.
And given how central the city has been in
the gay rights movement, the line was definitely
a shout out.
Frozen
Since its 2013 release, Frozen has become
one of Disney’s juggernauts.
The tale of two sisters is the highest grossing
animated film in history.
The story is good, and the soundtrack is catchy,
even though we’ve all heard it too many
times.
Thankfully, the writers reserved some of the
laughs for the grownups.
And one scene sticks out above the rest.
When Kristof is quizzing Anna about her love
life, he asks about her suitor’s shoe size.
She might have shrugged the question off but
we’re willing to bet that most of the adults
in the room got a kick out of that one.
Cars
If you’re in the public eye and good at
your job, chances are you have some fans.
And that’s doubly true for racer Lightning
McQueen.
He lights up the track and is unstoppable
wherever he goes.
People thought it would be tough to make something
like a car express emotions, but some cunning
animation proved all the naysayers wrong.
There is one subtle gesture that only adults
will pick up on though.
During an event, two sports-car groupies turn
on their high beams and the press goes wild
like girls on spring break.
Cars isn’t the first movie to compare a
woman’s chest to headlights, but it might
be the most subtle one.
Zootopia
Since it’s release of March this year, Zootopia
has grossed over one billion dollars worldwide.
Judy Hopps is a rabbit who’s always dreamed
of becoming a police officer.
Her city, Zootopia, is home to all different
animal species, but there has never been a
rabbit cop.
After making her way through training, Judy
faces many obstacles.
Audiences have spoken out about how the movie
is a mirror for issues society is facing today.
One character describes another as “articulate”;
a callback to the word being used as a racist
backhanded compliment.
And feminist scholars point to a scene where
everyone can reach their chair except Judy,
arguing the sequence is a metaphor for female
struggle in the workplace.
So what do you think of our list?
Know of any other dirty jokes hidden in kids
movies?
Tell us about them in the comments below,
and be sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
for more videos like this one.